[Música]
o esporte faz bem à saúde mas o
transportar os alimentos a alta
competição faz tudo menos bem
as dietas oxox no anima o atleta que já
é suficiente ou se está no treino filho
vai deixar de estar
[Música]
eu adoro um trem que chega fintou todo
roto e olho para trás e vejo que fiz as
coisas bem mas eu sofri durante treino
no ar nos falta
[Música]
aí quando tem seus princípios têm as
suas bases
é muito complicado alcançar todo o tempo
é tentar encaixar tudo num dia 24 horas
a fim de tentar dormir alguma coisa
[Música]
é muito complicado com não tem final da
competição com a família
como está numa cidade diferente tem
muita compreensão
até lá a gente está envolvida na minha
vida sejam os tutores do hospital sejam
os professores
infelizmente toda a gente tem um
companheiro de profissão forma o
objectivo primeiro eu era jogos
olímpicos ou a carreira porque a
carreira de atleta termina muito rápido
e eu tenho tempo para seus autores
16 anos já estava viajando a combater e
muitos pais querem ver nã s no país
disse que nem sequer queria sabiam não
não vou deixar pra lá os meus pais eu
devo tudo a uma vaga 761 seria 15
minutos de aquecimento com os
alongamentos influência e é portanto
como poetas eletronics mandar embora
aponte a jogar seria vossas próprias
referências também só isso mas na direto
para o aquecimento
[Música]
nós confirmamos com aquilo que somos
deixamos do programa inclui hoje não só
que eu quero ser o terceiro na hora do
ataque quando o terceiro melhor maneira
possível quer ser o melhor nome possível
melhorá lo num crescendo tem muito para
evoluir
[Música]
[Aplausos]
existe no nível que nós queremos estar
no nível que nós queremos chegar essa
palavra não pode não pode estar lá
nós estamos num treino o rapaz olha sei
quando é que esta casa não pode ficar
sem seu treinador a dizer aqui um jogo
lá no grêmio chenault a atriz na cabeça
sequer os jogos era é como carol casa
com o st
jorge por exemplo aquela pessoa que
nunca desistiu aquela pessoa que treinou
ainda mais do que aquilo que estava
conseguindo aquilo que os outros que
estão ao lado
achavam que era possível ele estar lá
merece estar lá eu fiz tudo aquilo que
era preciso completou o seu convite para
estar entre os melhores
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bush
o show de bola que hoje em dia
tá bom
para ruy marra contigo
[Música]
muito obrigada a deixar de fumar vai
ficar mais fraca no início e também isso
não funciona
se eu falar em números mas o bragança
tem 26 anos e é nesse e que se aqui em
guimarães vai tentar banda imagem criada
aqui em guimarães vai dar enquanto
apresenta os fãs devem ficar médico ea
boa música durante anos vi uma chegada
quase atrasada
consegui estar aqui para falar hoje
sobre o trabalho foi como é que eu vou
conseguir instalar e infelizmente estou
aqui hoje as raízes são muito fáceis
durar minha família foi muito forte
a família está aqui sentados um ao outro
por aí né público é meus amigos também
estão por aí alunos e um desconforto
enquanto a universidade vamos falar
assim ele só vai chegar nunca venho aqui
o vídeo e daquilo que é o pai quanto o
taekwondo é uma arte marcial evolui para
um desporto olímpico
o desporto olímpico são três carros dois
minutos com um minuto de intervalo para
marcar pontos
quando bem no colégio vale dois pontos
quando a banda cancelou três pontes até
um pontapé do ativo no colégio há 14
anos quando foi atingido na cabeça aos
cinco pontos e marcar mais pontos ganha
é assim tão fácil com três
a gente monta nas raízes da família
pronto até lá e sempre ajudando e entre
patagônia quando tinha 13 anos
passado dois anos foi quando as coisas
ficaram aqui mesma série
antes disso três que passaram durante a
semana para 3 depois de uma hora duas
horas tem por aí
em 2001
7 se não me engano eu fui campeã
nacional júnior x tenham acesso ao
acampar na tropa dos ônibus e fla fica
em terceiro lugar
pra mim isso foi ok eu tenho jeito para
a coisa já estava quero continuar a
fazer nós fazemos paz foi ok é humilde
até tem jeito até podemos deixá lo
seguir
eu só queria uma coisa tiver suas notas
na altura não sabia o que queria seguir
mas meus pais sabiam que eu tinha
capacidade para tirar mais do que dez
atores não me atingiram 21 disseram aqui
tem que ter boas notas porto não sabe o
que quer assistir
e quando saímos às ruas com do ano
quando acabar as que não sejam as suas
notas em um clube de escolher aquilo que
tu queres realmente se eu não sabia que
a criança se sabia que ia ficar nem
pensado em mim é usar nos apoiavam em
estava no décimo ano e já não estamos
por nós treinarmos já estavam usar os
autocarros por aí braga treinar e oque
iniciado enquanto a ciência o curso na
altura investigação e pensei o que
motiva vai ter sempre investigação e
entre a medicina
entrei no curso depois das enxurradas
agora passado nove anos já percebi que
continua até a oficina uma investigação
hoje terça a domingo não foi só isso que
permitiu além de ficar a treinar com os
meus colegas raio de cinco quilômetros
tinha a doença para dormir
tinha o cinto para treinar o time para
treinar a necessidade de um hospital
isso quer dizer que amanhã às seis e
meia já estava a treinar às 9 horas já
estava no hospital ou necessidade
depois às seis da tarde já estava de
volta aos treinos o time estava na
cantina nova estava em casa para estudar
falei assim outra vez
e aqui começa um parcial de 2010
eu acho que é isso que os pais não deram
um conhecido meu pai quando eu os
aguentei cinco princípios cortesia
integridade ea segurança ao tomilho
espírito nova e eu peguei misto e
fazendo os meus princípios
a primeira parte das prioridades essa
via
é querer fazer quando os pais atender
porque estava nu quando vê por que não
fosse uma fusão fosse o que fosse
mesmo sendo um atleta assim não aos 40
anos que eu vou continuar a viver isto e
uma letra a necessidade da minha mãe
disse eu quero um médico não quero me
fascina porque o fim do primeiro exame
pode chegar completamente lotado estava
a tentar fazer tudo 100% então alguém
privatista que em primeiro lugar tudo o
resto do tempo e é para medicina e
depois aqui eu sou parte ser prático do
porto num raio de cinco quilômetros
testar um lado do outro em ser um
enfarte silva havia semanas em que era
um treino de manhã e tarde e depois mais
fisioterapia e tudo mais
havia outras semanas em que era um
treino por dia e passar bem te vi tudo
isto há que haver exame por exemplo um
tipo de beleza e ser prático e 20 todo
material de estudo no telemóvel no total
a nova ação com as capas contraste com a
frente à nova assim como os fóruns e em
qualquer sítio e opinião as fontes lava
no mundo estava lá seus colegas tinham
seis horas postar essas nenhuma
verificação e essa coisa de ser prático
e flexível e ficado mais também também
se aplicam no segundo
em 2010 nós não temos quase desconhecido
na final
não tínhamos muito dinheiro é nosso país
pagará nossas viagens e então nós quer
fazer o circuito europeu e queremos
acumular pontos em experiência e tudo
que 50
então todas nossas viagens eram feitas
em a companhias low cost ou mais barato
ao grande por a 100 euros a 1 como
escala de 12 horas por 80 horas de
espera foi nem havia dúvidas sobre
nossas tentaram procurar o nosso time
vai ficar sozinha
ia ser um caminho mais longe do adn do
do pavilhão
mas mesmo assim temos transportes foi o
que representa mesmo o espírito disse
rasca do ser português é isto consegue
imaginar por que é que isto uma chaleira
nosso espaço está ok mil de ingênuos
acharam que era nas ruas aqui um bom
padeiro
a tap a oferta primária
ela então vou pois nela 50 euros não só
pagou quando a suíça vamos lá vamos
poupar dinheiro
procuraram nossa na áustria e na suíça
na mesma via em 2010
temos uma tela chegamos ao hotel serão
querem mais caro já não levantar os
troxas uma via cozinha então vamos ao
restaurante entramos estancado carro
aqui entramos no outro estão em um carro
caro é tudo muito caro pagar em dinheiro
para comer um prato de massa e no nosso
conseguia suportar isso
então vamos perguntar se uma chaleira e
possamos simboliza que menores em que o
prêmio cada refeição nós éramos quatro e
oprimido afeição aqui moda tal ficha
limpa todos logo à noite mais uma lata
de milho e era assim na vida
assim nós travamos músicos dodô só seis
para poupar dinheiro no no autocarro
para não ter o vilão em tela passou a
ser a nossa melhor amiga
vocês podem estar em qualquer parte do
mundo se inserem na tela se eu não tiver
a novela tem uma coisa por cima é muito
bom uma série agora guarda em staten vai
servir quem não estava a mentir sobre as
12 horas das escalas e tudo mais então
no irã ela pode fazer uma coisa bastante
comum
o primeiro prato de massa por aí a falar
em inglês é um luxo ou seja são
restaurantes alguém fala inglês que tem
que pagar os empregados que já gostava
de carga
então o restaurante locais só a senhora
não fala inglês como também coreana
eu acho que quando vim a entrar viu um
prato mais lá fora aqui trazendo assim
nunca fora olha é que nós queremos que
ele fez comigo pra minha cara faz todos
os animais e não tem problema nenhum
porque a comida foi muito bem
o nosso feijão que descobrimos que um
carro pode ter três marcas é grave e tem
um lado que é um sede também eram bem
dando e o carro era muito bom só temos
44 acidentes seus primeiros anos de vida
mas confiar mas existem resultados
na altura a prioridade era andar o
máximo de jogos possíveis ter o máximo
de experiência possível e com uma equipa
nós tivemos várias em fátima em todos os
outros em paz isto minou comigo a ser
vice-campeão do mundo em 2011 afp a
coreia 19 anos como o campeonato do
mundo
meu objetivo era ganhar combates e
celulares campeã do mundo foi foram
temos incrível a seguir se uma
estatística do que eu ia ser um dado de
prata nos jogos de 2012 tudo incrível
estou muito feliz mesmo
a temperatura estava em que ofendeu
apuramento para os jogos olímpicos de
na altura a parte do time estão mais não
foi unânime foi não ir aos jogos com a
parte esportiva na altura estava a ser a
voz do comité olímpico até se vice
campeã do mundo e deixa de ser sempre o
primeiro com jogos e aquela era a única
forma que eu via de desenvolver nosso
país seguiu sem investir em mim e depois
as coisas ficaram piores
isso aqui é o meu joelho fabiano durante
um ano um ano e meio não ganhei a
competição
as minhas condições acabavam minha pra
cá e passava dois ou três dias a fazer
fisioterapia no joelho inchado que andar
já que estava quanto mais treinar e
estou uma altura que foi ok para é
preciso olhar as coisas que lhe estou a
fazer uma coisa errada
as dietas estava tava está cada vez mais
tem um metro e oitenta fazer gols é
complicado é então fique rock band por
isso uma condição de 2013 - 58 quilos o
que ocorre banho efetivamente nós
estamos a trabalhar bem essa é uma maré
de azar ou então vamos lá ou por 68 e
e por isso também e foi das melhores já
a fim de ficar nos 58 quilos
depois disso foi campeão geral em 2014
ganha jogos europeus em 2015
fiquei pendurado atrás em 2016 já foi
número 1 do ranking mundial então que o
objetivo máximo estar nos jogos
olímpicos rio 2016 vem falar muitas
vezes em nós porque apesar de acontecer
um desporto individual
deus não sem os meus amigos têm os meus
colegas também não sou ninguém
esse é o número que o acompanhou desde
desde sempre
então depois disso voltaram das unidades
foram muitos meses que seu anjo já já
estava já havia até quando foram oito
meses em que eu me inspirava tudo era
voltar quando era treinada apresentada e
fisioterapia era contar que eu comia e
dormia e eu posso dizer que no dia 17 de
agosto 2007 os melhores dias da minha
vida
os jogos olímpicos na melhor forma de
sempre ganha o melhor combate porque a
pontual ou seja estamos há seis meses
mundo era conquistar a liga dos campeões
e ganhar por 10
é incrível como combate por um toque só
deu azar mesmo
mas mesmo assim não deixou de ser um dos
melhores da minha vida porque entrar
naquela arena em tê-la meus pais a irmã
namorada os meus amigos puxar por mim
foi uma energia indicativa
meu deus depois isto queria estar aqui
mas não fique férias e férias desligar
do mundo pra pensar para reavaliar as
coisas também como é que normalmente as
minhas prioridades
observei foi rigoroso pacote total em
assinei contrato com o benfica por 108
quilos
[Risadas]
aquele recurso porque na altura em que
ano para os jogos pois ninguém pausa e
voz e voltar a pensar em outra vez de
voltar à política desde que os porquês
700 casas que representam bem a gente
fica muito indo a região fica muito ruim
do que há seis anos cai mais linda do
mundo anunciam ter mais nada lembra
madrid enfrenta agora é continuar assim
tenho mais intensas minhas a lei vamos
fazendo falta dos meus clientes a ajuda
também parece algumas medalhas ou três
fazendo muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]